out to the 23rd annual Latin Grammy
awards that ceremony is happening this
Thursday night here in Las Vegas we
stopped by this year's gift Lounge to
check out what the Stars will be getting
this year
we are celebrating the 23rd annual land
Grammys and one thing that people don't
often know is that the presenters and
the performers are actually not paid to
be here so they do get to come into this
exclusive gift Lounge but it's the way
for the Academy to thank them for
participating and this year they're
getting some fun stuff that's going to
make them all feel a winner regardless
of what happens on Thursday night so
right off the bat I'm going to tell you
Mirage it's very quickly been my fan
favorite if you remember the Grammys
they actually were a big hit at the
Grammys with the artist because their
technology is really amazing it's
actually waterless molecules which means
that there's no fillers it allows it to
penetrate into your skin a lot quicker
which increases the efficiency who
doesn't want to look younger and feel
fresher right and so they're getting a
five piece system for them to have so
everything from a wash to something for
their eyes and their lips and of course
that lotion for day and night now moving
on from there I have to tell you Maria
ganesa I am so pumped if you're Latin
you already know that is a household
Staple in our homes right so this year
what they are doing doing is they're
partnering up with three different
Latina small business women owners which
I really love you'll see that one of
them already designed the cover here for
the Box inside there's a little tote bag
as well as a mug and then they're
inviting each of the artists to share
that one piece of Priceless nuggets of
wisdom that they were received from a
special woman in their life whether it's
their mom their girlfriend their
daughter and really share that to pay it
forward so I really love celebrating El
Amor De Mama the love of mom if you will
now you might notice my jacket is nice
and puffy and I really am about our next
big person here or product that we have
and it's from Peta and they have their
no fur movement that they have and we're
all celebrating about that right so this
year they actually are hooking everybody
up with a Mirai bag Mariah 1998 in
addition with a wallet y'all made out of
tea leather now we do know that wearing
fashion on what you wear has become a
thing and so Bacardi is no different
they actually created this limited
edition denim jacket it has the Bacardi
logo on the back and on the front it
says Latin Grammys 2022 and with that
they're giving everybody a custom land
Grammy 2022 labeled bottle of their
Infamous rum and it's been cool if
you've already seen walking around we
have some Talent making themselves at
home at that particular station to
getting some drinks now moving right
along with the drinks we also have 1800
cristiliano
which I love giving everybody this huge
case so it comes not only with the
liquor itself but you're gonna get two
glasses so that you can make that red
carpet moment for you at home and if
that wasn't enough you can Dazzle it off
with the Little Nail
customized for you right here by two
different celebrity nail manicures and
there's even a mani cab so I'm super
pumped and then to round it all off we
have Frontera wine some of my favorite
wines from Chile so that we can toast to
that special moment in your life